this to sex so obviously that's why i'm
asking what's the normal amount because
you've got sex or corn sex right okay so
be careful what you say
once a day
once once a day so seven days a week
every day once why is it once like that
why are you questioning me like that
what do you guys think a normal amount
is hear from the guy so she says once a
day what about you
before i answer
once a day because you think it's right
or is that what you give
no i don't give every single day okay
because you said that if you were
sitting there you'd say he'd want more
yeah exactly but i'm saying within
reason you would yeah i'm saying because
life children yeah yeah schedules
you being tired you're being awake it
doesn't always work yeah but if it could
work i did yeah yeah
but is is your sex drive still like that
though once a
day you just saying that because you're
thinking that would be the man's sex
drive
no i
i we've had conversations and um
i said okay so what's your like what
would you want a week let's say for
example and i think he said something
like
four times a week something like that
wow okay
kudos to him four times a week
why'd you say kudos what you want more
100
i don't think there's a number it's just
whenever whenever whenever i'm aroused
whenever we we're both aroused it could
be
it won't be four times a week but have
you got children
see this is what i'm saying when you
even
if you've got if you haven't got you you
can't speak about kids you ain't got
kids
i'm telling you sorry kids are no kids
because if you have an itch
that needs to be scared if you've got a
17 year old it does the room next door
that can hear yeah yeah you can't be uh
i mean that's a category
that's a corn category yeah abuse
dad please don't obvious
pearl said
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think i don't think it
matters i think i think if you're if
you're fully dedicated to
to pleasure
yeah but remember remember we're having
conversations in in a long-term
monogamous relationship with children
and families
and as much as we would like them not to
they do impact our daily life yeah 100
and what i'm saying is i would like to
have it every day
and if i if i didn't have children and i
was i don't know living in bali
near a beach and i could do whatever i
liked i would want it every day maybe
more than once a day yeah i want to know
what the guys say so what
like how much would you guys want it to
just be on demand
how does and when sorry go ahead yeah no
i would say
i would say as annoying um
but obviously i'm also understanding
that yeah life is real yeah and some
days you're tired some days you're not
but
so what you sorry go and go
can i get
every day
no no no not for me i'd say
four times a week three four times a
week okay have you ever been tired and
had sex anyway
yeah but often but i'm different so that
lazy i don't watch i don't watch corn
and i don't
no way
yeah good for you you you you don't
retain that scene yourself
help
that's what you're saying you say you
don't do self-help yeah good for you man
because i understand and you will
understand the deplete feeling after the
tiredness all of those things i think is
it speaks more volumes for your
self-control if you can
hold that in yeah because i think that's
the hardest thing in life to control
other than eating the physical craving
for the opposite sex is the hardest
thing to to control in any form and i
think corn plays a massive factor in not
having to have any self-control yeah
what what benefits have you what
benefits have you seen from cutting that
out
um for me increased longer erections
increased confidence um it's just the
way you carry yourself
especially when
if you can have intercourse
and not do it the feeling of um
describes almost like a superpower
because
men will know what it's like and women
when you get to that point when you know
you're going to climax you're like
there's no going back i'm not even going
to try and stop it but if you can get
yourself to that point and still please
your partner and kind of step away from
it for your own self-control mm-hmm
it does so much more for you
okay i'm a virgin so i don't know what
you're going to do
yeah so what would you guys say
unlimited sex with your like girl you're
you're dating someone but if you're in
love with someone what would you do um
that josh said like three four times
three four times jesus christ
but the thing is we're talking about the
thing is you're talking about the thing
is probably why josh is saying that's
probably why i'm saying it too it's
because we understand logistics of
relationships and children and stuff
like that so we're saying that
based on the logistics of the
relationship okay it's on the tip of
your ti i need to know i don't think i'd
say two to
two to three times a day
yeah
because we're not talking long
hour sessions as a necessity like
okay so
you okay i feel like sex is very
important in a relationship extremely
important i feel like it's important to
keep the flame alive
i've had i've had relationships where
the flame just dies and then a touch is
a bit like you know and it's like that's
this hardness how can you how can you
improve that the only way to improve it
is
whenever you see your pa whenever you
see your partner a touch or grope a kiss
or whatever and any one of those can
lead to sex there shouldn't be any any
sort of we can't do it now even if it's
a five minute quickie whatever it is it
should just continue because once you
settle down in the
okay maybe tomorrow okay maybe in two
days maybe in three days it's going to
it's going to eventually just be the
norm not to and to plan ahead as opposed
to yeah the kids are can i ask what's
been your like longest relationship
though ten years
and within that you were getting it two
three times a day every day no no
so that's in terms of learning from that
in the beginning you do but after a
while you just get you grow you grow out
of it because of life you know you're
going to work you're coming back 6 p.m
you're tired you're hungry you're just
focusing on making a meal eating you're
blowing it you're tired you're asleep
what i mean like without the kids you
know
no but but you allow those things to
happen you allow that to become the
reality do you know what i'm trying to
like
it's
i'm accommodating to that so if my
partner comes home and she's tired i'm
like oh you're tired it's fine let's
leave it and then
we're just both accommodating life
affecting that the habit of us having
sex and eventually
you're going weeks will have without
having sex because you're understanding
okay yeah we are tired oh yeah we do
have kids and then even you're strangers
to each other i'm just saying like what
you're gonna do for a living if you're
having sex two three times a day
at night do you not feel like
you're kind of
you're
you're almost forcing if you're having
it two three times yeah all right okay
let me let me put an input this way so
all right so if i see if if i'm looking
at my partner
there's no limits on how many times i
can kiss her right kissing is an
expression of affection let's just say
at the base level
so i can never look at kissing okay well
this is a bit too much i'm forcing this
kiss because it's reciprocated so sex
why would sex be different why would why
would i look at kissing as
as
normal
and i can kiss her as many times but
when it's sex it's it's not the same
when it sucks it's forcing because you
go on trying to say because you got
stuff to do throughout the day bro like
yeah of course you do but but if even
three times a day no but nobody if
my partner might
have cleaned up the house cooked me
dinner and i'll give her a kiss as a
sign of affection and a thank you i'm
not gonna be like baby bend over the
counter
let me know
so there's different types of kissing
there's a there's a peck on the lips
it's just you know it's just it's
habitual yeah but we're not you know i'm
talking snogging like passionately
kissing
it's not
like in relationships it starts up it
starts off here go on go on paul just
look at how much time this would take
i mean the main session can last an hour
and many other sessions could be like 10
20 minutes okay so it's like an hour and
a half daily yeah it can't be three
hours each time you're gonna kill
yourself people go and work nine to five
yeah but you go shower you gotta wash
again you gotta um
no morning morning sex is
you have to in the morning baby wipes
yeah do you know what i mean
again you guys that you it's not well
i'm not talking full-on sessions
any penetration would do a lick
and then when you come back you have the
proper the proper session and before
because i can ask you a question yeah
would you say
that in those two three times yeah